in china young people under 18 will only
be allowed to play video games up to
three hours a week after the government
announced new restrictions esports
organizations have been working to
comply with these new regulations by
removing minors from their competitive
rosters so what does this mean for the
chinese gaming scene as a whole let's
talk about it
[Music]
all right so before i explain all these
new policies and how they're gonna
impact the chinese gaming scene i gotta
remind you to check out our new show
cracked which combines the world of tech
and esports be sure to check out our
latest episode which teaches you how to
optimize your in-game settings presented
by amd so this all started when chinese
state news agency hua reported on august
30th that starting september 1st china's
national press and publication
administration would start to curb the
time young people spent on playing video
games the new regulations say that
developers can allow their online game
services to be only played by miners so
anyone under 18 from 8pm to 9pm on
friday saturday and sunday as well as
holidays and online game services not a
super detailed definition but as far as
i can tell that means online platforms
like steam and plain online games like
league of legends will be affected by
this also developers must make sure that
people are logging in with their quote
real name registration and logins and
prevent anyone that fails to do so from
playing it's important to note that this
is not a new law rather this is a new
policy that companies must abide by and
it makes sense that given in the past
gaming has been called a spiritual opium
by state publication the article was
later then taken down and then reposted
without that term being in it but
then on september 9th the south china
morning post reported that china would
actually halt on approving new online
games the nppa which is in charge of
licensing video games in the country has
not published the list of approved
titles for august breaking its routine
of announcing newly licensed games
either in the middle or at the end of
each month since may 2019 between 80 to
100 games are usually approved each
month later on october 1st the
associated press reported that further
restrictions we put onto games this time
regarding in-game content specifically
there would be a ban on quote effeminate
males gay relationships and games that
had no distinct or clear moral choices
now this almost sounds a little jarring
to you if you're anything like me after
work you hop into discord and play a
little bit of everything for as long as
you can before you go to bed
if you go to bed china bans under 18s
from playing video games more than three
hours a week a week
huh
a week but in order to explain how this
happened why it's actually not that
shocking i gotta bring you back and
explain how we got to this point now
it's also important to say that china is
a country of over 1 billion people with
a incredibly long history and a very
complex government the situation is much
more nuanced than a video like this in
cover in the time we have today china
has been worried about adverse reactions
to video games specifically addiction to
them for an example as to why this might
be in 2011 a man lost consciousness in a
gaming cafe outside of beijing after
supported he did not eat or sleep much
for three days he later died according
to the south china morning post this
past march president xi jinping quote
explicitly listed game addiction as a
concern for the psychological health of
the country's teens china has tried to
remedy this with private army-like camps
made to treat web addiction with methods
that include
beatings solitary confinement and
electroshock therapy this has led to
injuries and deaths in the children that
attend these camps with some of these
camp facilitators being brought before a
court while gaming addiction is a
growing problem across the world people
have noticed that this is a symptom of a
much larger issue of toxic work cultures
you know are video games kind of
addictive
yeah absolutely and we're going to talk
about that in a second but i think that
what people here are missing is that
there's a confluence of events that gets
young people
uninterested in participating in society
and then when i choose not to
participate in society because i don't
get paid enough i don't get enough
respect i don't enjoy my job it's not
fulfilling then i choose not to
participate in society and when i choose
not to participate in society what do i
do with all my time and so what i end up
doing with all my time is like video
games these new regulations are also
part of a recent crackdown the chinese
government has had on their tech and
entertainment industries rules and
regulations like this aren't new to the
chinese gaming scene in 2019 similar but
less harsh regulations were put in that
barred miners from playing games from
the hours of 10 pm to 8 am with a time
limit of 90 minutes national holidays
were the exception with a time limit of
three hours fortune also reported that
quote the rules instituted in 2019
created content guidelines that banned
gory images like blood promoted chinese
culture and said gambling-like features
such as loot boxes must be labeled with
the odds of winning censorship is
nothing new to china china has outright
banned media for being shown in the
country that they simply don't want to
be seen some of you may remember when
battlefield 4 was banned for being sold
in the country or when the censorship of
any images that connected president xi
jinping and winnie the pooh winnie the
pooh looking [ __ ] despite all of
this there are still major concerns by
the chinese esports scene in order to
become a pro player you obviously have
to practice your game but if you're only
able to play up to three hours a week
how could you possibly get good or even
learn to like a game now if you're
anything like me you might think that
young kids could possibly dodge this by
using a vpn or a separate adult account
but like i said that could become
increasingly hard when you're forced to
use your real name and information and
the developers are being asked to take
an extra security step by the government
tencent actually announced that they'll
be using ai and facial recognition to
help comply with these new regulations
it must get real hard to swerve in china
and just to show how these regulations
are being upheld fortune reported on an
incident where at 3am a player managed
to get a penta kill in the ever popular
mobile game honor kings a fellow player
noticed that the pentakiller's account
belonged to a 60 year old gaming
profiles in china display birth years
and posted it on china's twitter like
weibo the post went viral and weibo
users concluded that the skilled gamer
was likely not a six-year-old at all but
rather a kid who has swiped a relative's
phone tencent said the gamer's profile
had passed 17 facial recognition age
checks this year still it couldn't
definitely conclude that a sexogenerian
had executed the pentakill and therefore
couldn't rule out that the player had
violated draconian veto game laws that
china had made even stricter on
september 1st with all this being said
chinese players have been working
playing and practicing with these types
of restrictions since 2019 and china's
performance hasn't been bad at all
they've often dominated league of
legends in the past few years and rng
won msi back in may and it's not just
china who's had to practice under these
types of restrictions in 2011 a law was
introduced in south korea that
prohibited anyone under 16 from playing
video games between 12am and 6am that
law either known as the shutdown law or
the cinderella law will actually be
rolled back and allow for parents and
guardians to choose their specific
curfews young players have still come
from internet cafes then to academy
teams and then to the main rosters and
they are all still powerhouses but we
have not seen regulations as strict as
china's most recent development some
people are happy with the regulations
saying this will fix a large problem
regarding kids and games on the other
hand there are people sharing major
concerns with privacy and government
control after all it is your face and
name that will be used to prove your
identity the new york times reported
that an esports professional hau shu who
owns a training center said there are
enough players in the mix to sustain the
scene for now so effects from these
restrictions might not be felt for a
while however the south china morning
post reported that an esports technical
director named warren lee said quote
under this new regulation there is
pretty much zero chance to train the
next generation of esports competitors
personally i can't imagine what this
means for esports team owners in china
right now and he may have a point
in the days after the first regulations
were announced ren lpl reported from a
translated weibo post that the league of
legends development league or ldl was
complying with them by blocking anyone
who was under 18 from competing they
also delayed matches that were supposed
to happen that week as rosters probably
scrambled to fill the now empty spots as
of september 2nd about 31 players have
been dropped from the lpl and ldl for
being under 18. this includes 17 year
old lynn cream john who just won rookie
of the split the lpl 2021 summer split
he has since been removed from his
team's roster on his organization's
website now despite all of this we're
only still about a month into these new
restrictions while there have been
immediate consequences we still don't
know what the long-term effects on the
chinese esports scene will be and the
same goes for the content bands we don't
know how games will be changed to be
released in china if they'll be changed
at all and how this will affect original
chinese games only time will tell how
this will all play out and if china will
place further restrictions on their
games and the people that play them
then on september 9th
there's this other girl who can sing
like
oh god colton have fun with that one
rules and regulations like this aren't
new to the chinese gaming sim scene yeah
the gaming sun
you get a high five danny
not keith though what's something that
winnie the pooh says that's like hey i
said i got any other catchphrase
i suppose you're great
wait why are you so good at it danny
why are you so good at that
yeah right okay honestly